and i want to get right to it we're
going to be praising aaron rodgers
throughout the show because he had
multiple throws that were flat out off
the charts old school phenomenal yeah he
moves around like a guy 10 years younger
than he is the things he did yesterday
were as impressive as anything he's ever
done and i'm saying all of that because
it's setting up the big concern i have
coming out of the game i'm gonna get
right to it yeah last hour i i took some
time to get to my my main criticism and
look you know how i feel about the
seahawks i've been big supporters of
what they do russell wilson's great pete
carroll's great yada yada
but here's what's bothering me this
morning about that game and the jimmy
graham thing is going to provide the
seahawks some cover for this because
everybody's going to be you know
criticizing scrutinizing the whole idea
of the spot right right let's forget
about that let's forget about that
three minutes and 22 seconds left in the
game right
russell wilson gets sacked by preston
smith the seahawks have the ball on
their own 36th fourth and 11. yeah 322
three timeouts two minute warning
down five
and it's russell wilson who was playing
almost as well as aaron rodgers and
maybe as well as aaron rodgers doing
vintage russell wilson things i heard
some quotes
of packers players after the game they
said it was like trying to chase a
chicken in a yard with no fence that you
know and that's and you see defensive
lineman all the time get frustrated
because they just can't get russell
wilson
fourth and eleven chris here's a
we can get into the analytics and the
probabilities and the statistics and and
if you do this then what are the chances
of this that
it's fourth and eleven and you have
russell wilson they have aaron rodgers
you have three timeouts there's three
minutes left in the game
how how does it take
anything more than a knee-jerk automatic
thought of course we're going for it
here we're not gonna punt it to aaron
rodgers we've seen what aaron rodgers
has done all game we're not stopping
aaron rodgers we're trusting our guy you
trust your guy against green bay's
defense over aaron rodgers against your
defense every day of the week don't you
well yeah i don't think it has to come
down to that first off pete carroll's a
defensive coach mike we've seen him do
this a lot the whole year right he's not
one doesn't make it right no it doesn't
make it right but i do think there's
logic here i don't think it's totally
stupid you know yes where he's at 28 23
okay you know i think pete carroll is
looking at it going all right but if
it's fourth and 11 and we don't get the
first down yeah they're going to kick a
field goal they're going to go up by
eight who knows how much time is going
to be left all right then we're gonna
have to go down and score a touchdown
two-point conversion he aired on you
know i don't like my chances of
converting on fourth and eleven they've
been doing a pretty good job of
pressuring wilson you're right russell
wilson's magic man but i think he went
my defense just made a stop you know
more than likely green bay is going to
throw the ball on first and second down
and i think pete carr was just hoping
hey it's going to come down to one play
and i hope my defense on a certain third
down can make that type of stop and they
didn't do it
here's the thing okay wait wait wait
okay yeah it's gonna come down to one
play all right if it comes down to one
play i want russell wilson for that one
play not my defense trying to stop aaron
rodgers in his own building that's the
thing we can complicate the analysis all
we want but it comes down to believing
in your guy
over
believing in their guy and their guy and
your guy are both two of the best in the
league and i just think when you have
the ball
and and it's a five-point game and
there's three minutes left
and you've got russell wilson
and they've got aaron rodgers i don't
care about analytics there and i
understand and there's al there's layers
and levels to where the analytics is
the analytics i mean what you know again
we don't know but it's fourth and eleven
too the analytics of the percentage of
probably uh you know getting the first
down there and converting have to be
very low as well exactly but but that's
but but those numbers are all generated
week in and week out with a a wide
variety of quarterbacks aren't russell
wilson you've got you've got a guy who
is making more money than anyone else in
the nfl right now you believe in him
yeah by virtue of what you're paying yes
and he and and pete carroll said after
the game
russell wilson was phenomenal tonight he
did everything he could for us to win
the game right there's a point where you
just have to say you know what
we've got the guy to do it all those
analytics are based on a bunch of stiffs
and and a wide swath of quarterback from
good to bad and everything in between
we've got one of the best and we trust
him at fourth and eleven and oh by the
way if we give him the ball back they've
got one of the best well yeah i get you
and i guess that's my concern here okay
listen i know i mean you're not crazy i
think the 11 part is the big issue like
if it was fourth and you know if he
doesn't take the five yard sack that
doesn't happen and it's fourth and eight
or less i think he goes for it but i
also think we got to take into account
too that he's also looking at it like
okay this is a defensive coach this is a
guy who went to two super bowls playing
through his defense so this is what he
thinks and he thinks about that he
always has faith that they're gonna make
the stop and you know that's the that's
kind of his mo i i also think he's got
to come into play like to what you're
saying with aaron rodgers too all right
it's just going yeah all right maybe
they have a third and eight now or a
third and whatever you know backed up
let's say russell wilson and then went
for it don't get it
now what if aaron rodgers throws that he
is that guy like you're mentioning he
throws a touchdown on one of those third
down plays what if they're right there
by the red zone on that third down play
and he throws a similar route to devonta
adams bam touchdown game over so i think
he looked at it like all right i'm
either gonna have to score a touchdown
of the two-point conversion or man
rogers is pretty good maybe he throws a
touchdown and just like puts the dagger
on us and we're done or i can punt the
ball
and rely on my defense and maybe a
stupid play call or a really
conservative wimpy call by a green bay
to maybe do it listen i hear you it's a
tough decision russell wilson was
unbelievable yesterday i feel like we've
reversed in time where you know a few
years ago russell wilson had defense and
a run game to help him and it was aaron
rodgers doing everything by himself now
it's the opposite aaron rodgers got a
little defense and a run game to help
him and i want to be like man can
anybody on seattle do something besides
russell wilson he was unreal yesterday
what he did he carried that team and you
know unfortunately they just don't have
enough offense and it always comes down
to oh gosh we're down by 18. let's just
let russell fly now and it's like well
it's too late you're down by 18 at
lambeau field it's just too much to
overcome uh i hear your point but i
don't think i'm going to sit here and
eviscerate and be totally mad at pete
carroll there he is and we showed the
highlights the first clip we showed was
russell wilson getting bottled up in the
backfield squirting through and running
for like 25 yards yeah and maybe the
play maybe the pl maybe the play call
would be in that fourth and eleven send
everybody deep have russell take three
steps back and russell just go get us 11
yards it's russell wilson that's that's
my
point here i get you
and this is where
and i think there's a place for
analytics
but you have to remember who you have
and who they have when you're running
the numbers through the computers like
if you've got lamar jackson it's very
easy to be gutsy on fourth and three
fourth and four and if you've got
russell wilson and and really the list
of quarterbacks that you would trust to
get you fourth and eleven with the
season on the line is not a long one and
russell wilson is on that list here's
another thing too chris and this and
maybe this helps further explain why
pete carroll is a defensive coach
throughout the second half there were
moments where
i'm wondering do the seahawks realize
they're down 18 points like the urgency
wasn't there the touchdown drive that
they after it went to 28 to 10. taking a
lot of time taking a lot of time and on
that play when they decided to punt
fourth and eleven yeah the play ended
with 322 on the clock right they punted
they they got the snap off with 241.
that's a lie
that bothered me mike i'm with you there
i saw that and i went okay we're punting
the ball let's let's punt it and get the
show on the road here you're right they
let a lot of a lot of clock run off now
to the bigger point of what you said hey
we talked about this over the weekend
right you know i i had brought up when
we were sitting in the van going over
the going over to the 49ers stadium hey
the seahawks are scary you know i had
this conversation with my buddy kyle
shanahan a few weeks back about the
seattle seahawks where yeah it's just
like
they don't care how the game goes
they play the seattle seahawks and pete
carroll to give russell wilson the ball
in the last drive of the game they just
want to be okay let's mix up when they
punt except when they punt on fourth
down he didn't like it on fourth and
eleven i hear you but they're still but
you're right i get you i know i know but
but that's the way they play right mike
we saw it even in the in the week 17
game against the 49ers they were down by
14 in the fourth quarter and they were
still
snapping the ball with two and three
seconds left on the play clock they're
scary that way they have no fear and
russell wilson of course is a magic man
so i that that's what they do and i'm
not going to be mad at him for that i
hear you with the pun thing and i the
the fourth and 11 is debatable i get it
i think if i was pete carroll i would
have done what he did too i would have
probably punted it try to get my defense
to get the stop get russell the ball one
time see where it goes from there but uh
i think the questions are it's a good
debate and a good conversation
yeah i i uh i i agree with you on that
but but so much as you're saying that i
keep coming back to yeah i know you do
you've got russell wilson he is the
magic man and what an opportunity for
him to add to his legend you know he'll
never say it publicly and he may only
ever say it privately to his wife
and even then he'll he'll kind of shrug
and say hey you know we've won a lot of
champ you know we won a championship
we've had a lot of success but at some
level he's got to be thinking pete why
did you take the ball out of my hands in
that moment i could have done it and uh
aaron rodgers did it and and look oh
rodgers
he really and see what you get from
having faith
in the seahawks i'm such an idiot you
know i made some bets with the some
friends earlier in the week and took the
packers and the 49ers and as the week
went on i went oh gosh gedavion clowney
seems like he's healthy and i got all
caught up in all these damn things and
you're right that's what i get aaron
rodgers burn my butt way to go a-rod way
to go
that throw to jimmy graham over the top
there it is yeah dropped it in
because it was this one it was 20 it was
21 to 10
third and nine
and and here come the seahawks and if
the if the packers don't convert there
it could be 21-17 with a lot of time
left in the game and he dropped that
ball over the top to jimmy graham it was
a thing of beauty and then there was
that devonta adams where he just flat
out abused trey flowers twice on the cut
out to make the catch and then the cut
back in to run to the end zone ran by
him ran by quandary diggs and 21-10
quickly i mean even that throw there
right at the end of the game just he i
mean his feet are all over the place
sorry i didn't mean to cut you off but
just no you're fine his feet are all
over the place right you're like oh gosh
it looks like he's getting pressure
who's he getting it off to and it's like
both feet are in the air and he's fading
away and there's a great catch by jimmy
graham and hey debatable spot i get that
too uh but yeah you're right i don't
know what the hell i was thinking you
don't you don't go against the great one
when he's at home in green bay and that
was uh a great performance by him and
the green bay packers and like again
it's like the green bay packers all year
we kind of go
it wasn't like the most impressive but
they got it done they won again it's
just the way they play and that's kind
of what's scary about green bay too
they're very comfortable in these one
score fourth quarter football games i've
watched some of the game last night my
wife said aaron rodgers that's the guy
chris likes right i said well like isn't
the word that's chris's guy the greatest
quarterback of all time and he played
like it last night chris sims
unbelievable throws by aaron rodgers one
after another and just the way he moves
he moves with the i effortless ness he
floats like a butterfly he stings like a
bee
he doesn't look like he's 36
right we talk about all these older
quarterbacks trying to hold it together
until father time finally whacks him
over the head with his big hourglass
aaron rodgers looks great well he just
got great you know great feat he's a
great athlete he's always been able to
run
uh he's kept himself in shape you know
he's talked about you know tom brady the
things he's done that's rubbed off on
him and yeah he's just uh he's a
specimen that way and he's doing the
right things off the field to where yes
36 37 38 i don't think we're going to
see a tremendous drop off here from
aaron rodgers and you know added to it
you know what we saw early in the game
too mike aaron rodgers great yes we know
it
but
some good game planning too you know
just what the way they came out early on
ran the ball yeah the rand get the run
game kind of fell apart as the game went
on but it jump started them early which
allowed them to hit a few play-action
passes and then you know the great and
this goes back to mike again the seattle
seahawks play the seattle scheme which
you know i can't stand because it's so
predictable and they know things right
the first touchdown pass to devonte
adams they had a good feel that seattle
might try to switch it off right
remember that play there the coverage
they try to switch it off you know
damonte adams makes it looks like he's
gonna run the slant and then ends up
going with the go route and seattle's
trying to to switch it with their two
dbs and yeah they knew that was coming
uh but roger is just so poised and calm
and just still has certainly one of the
best arms in the game uh and really and
really was big time last night with just
the third down throws consistently
through the game that is quarterback
down third down and he just came through
time after time after time
devonta adams had eight catches for 160
yards that was a green bay post season
record a couple of touchdowns and jimmy
graham sighting last night three of them
he had the big catch over the top and he
had the the catch that that iced the
game and uh i don't know if it gave him
a little extra juice because he was
going against the seahawks and remember
when he went to seattle how there was
this weird disconnect where
like from within the building they were
oh he's not a very good blocker well you
didn't you didn't trade for him to come
block right you traded for him to be a
pass catcher and there was always a
sense of dysfunction there and i just
wonder whether he got a little extra
satisfaction out of doing what he did
last night to the seahawks you know he
did definitely i mean had some huge
catches and huge moments right not just
the one at the end of the game you know
you you mentioned it earlier in the show
it was 21 to 10 and you felt like oh man
russell's got his mojo watch out they
make a stop right here seattle's gonna
get the ball back it's gonna come down
it's going to be 21-17 and rogers and
green bay's offense answers right on the
third date where he throws that
beautiful ball you mentioned in the
first segment where he's running that
deep inside crossing route they got a
safety over the top of them but rogers
throws the perfect throw to a guy that's
a giant human being and you just can't
defend it i don't care if you got two
defenders there or not but he he did he
added you know added some uh added
something to their offense last night
and sometimes that jimmy graham bothers
me because he he does disappear at
moments but last night he was big time
mike also leflore deserves credit for
the game planning some of the things we
saw you know the the little speed toss
sweeps like the kyle shanahan things
that we've seen you know he gave his
offense and his team an advantage early
on to let them get in the game and get
flowing and get going and feeling good
and confident and that's what a good
coach does and from there they they kind
of took it and the players continued to
play and then they took advantage of
that momentum
and also to hold it all together when it
feels like it's collapsing i mean it was
an 18 point lead that they almost
squandered at home right and they didn't
and and and that that la and you know
that look we we criticized the seahawks
earlier for giving the ball back to the
packers but it was hardly automatic that
they were able to get those two first
downs and keep things going it still
required the offense to move the ball
aaron rodgers to make a play and it
really is a lot easier to look like a
good head coach when you number one have
aaron rodgers and number two let aaron
rodgers be aaron rodgers and so here's
matt lafleur 14 and three and it's never
been
a dominant performance it's never been
wired a wire they're the better team on
the field but they've managed to win 14
out of 17 games and now they're they're
going right back to one of the places
where they got shellac this year one of
the only places they've had three losses
yep two or more on the road right both
were ugly both were in california and
they're going back to the general
vicinity of aaron rodgers upbringing and
they get a chance and that's i'll tell
you what i think we're going to see a
different packers i do so in the regular
season i do too i'm with you there you
know i think it's going to be a great
advantage for them that they've already
been there and know what they're about
to deal with i do and yes you know
they've got they're a better football
team now than they were then i think
they're even a little better running the
ball they'll know what to expect pass
protection protection wise uh their
defense is playing better hey this is a
number of weeks in a row we've seen
their run defense kind of sure up and
that was an issue for them so i think
they will be a pain in the butt for this
49ers team i expect it to be a close
football game
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports